russia is escalating its attacks across
ukraine russian forces are reported to
be intensifying fighting in the suburbs
of the capital and have also stepped up
their bombardment of keefe emergency
services say at least two people were
injured in new strikes on the city this
morning
for residents of the ukrainian capital
every passing day brings further
shelling more homes lost
and more casualties
is she alive
yes she's alive get her in the car
a city-wide curfew was imposed on
tuesday and will last until thursday
morning
ahead of the curfew people rushed to the
stores to stock up on food and supplies
the situation in the city is not bad
people are holding up
we're supported by the volunteers and
the territorial defense
meanwhile president vladimir celenski
said he saw hope for compromise in talks
between russia and ukraine even as
moscow stepped up its assault
it is important it's difficult but
important because any war ends in an
agreement
meetings continue
as i'm told the positions in the
negotiations sound more realistic
however there still needs to be more
time for decisions to be in ukraine's
interests
on tuesday leaders from three eu
countries visited kiev bringing a
message of support they reiterated their
desire to give ukraine a way to join the
eu as soon as possible
i hope it should be agreed over the next
couple of
days or weeks and the candidate status
should be given till the end of this
year at the latest
thank you
the capital bracing for the next round
this medical team has set up a field
hospital in a bomb shelter for the worst
case scenario of having to treat the
wounded here
the people of kyiv know their ordeal is
far from over
well for more let's bring in our
correspondent alexander for now she's in
levithan eastern western ukraine
alexandra there's been increased
shelling in and around the capital keefe
what's the situation there what are you
hearing
kiev is under a curfew that was
announced yesterday with the city's
mayor urging all residents to seek
shelter to take cover because the
russian forces are apparently
intensifying their attacks on the
ukrainian capital we know that heavy
fighting is going on on the outskirts of
kiev we know that there were explosions
in the city center
there are also reports about
russian missiles uh striking
apartment building that is quite close
to the center so this uh 12-floor
apartment building was apparently struck
and first responders were trying to get
people out of the apartment some of the
of them were on fire this morning
um as i said earlier you're in a level
that's in the west of ukraine where it's
relatively quiet
but are people there worried that the
violence the shelling the bombardment
will soon reach that part of the country
as well
they are worried of course they are
scared many uh told me that they think
that it's just a question of time before
the war will come here as well we just
have to remember that only a few days
ago a military training center just 30
kilometers away from life was struck by
russian missiles so people are scared
and we just have to stress the
importance of the weave that is only not
not only an important hub for aid
deliveries towards the eastern part of
the country but it's also a place where
many people flee they flee the fighting
in the eastern part of ukraine and then
they move on to travel on
across the border to poland or other
european nations
alexander we heard in our report there
that president zielenski uh is more
optimistic he said he believes russia
may now be more open to negotiations
that their position might as he put it
be more realistic now
what are we to make of that
well he really sounded cautiously
optimistic um
suggesting that russia has softened its
stance not demanding anymore that
ukraine surrender
we also heard from some senior members
of the negotiating team one of them said
that there is room for compromise
however he also added that there are
still
big differences contradictions between
the two sides
we know that what is at the table
apparently both sides are discussing
that is a future neutrality of ukraine
and according to past statements that
could be something that the ukrainian
government could be potentially ready to
discuss with the president zilinski
saying that ukraine has to accept that
it will not become a member of nato
despite the open door policy of the
alliance but of course both sides seem
to be still far apart uh with regard to
their positions
dw correspondent alexandra naman there
thank you very much alexander
russia's foreign minister sergey lavrov
has said that he sees quote some hope
for reaching a compromise in
negotiations with keefe that's after
ukrainian president vladimir zelinsky
also sounded a positive note on the
ongoing talks as we heard earlier in an
interview with russian tv channel rbk
lavrov said that a neutral status is
being seriously discussed in connection
with security guarantees the
uh there are concrete formulations that
in my view are close to being agreed
let's now bring in uh michael barcichu a
global affairs analyst with the atlantic
council um let's
start
uh
with this michael ukraine and russia are
now indicating that there's hope for a
compromise
uh to end the war
what do you think that would look
like uh good to be with you well if you
had asked me this very same question a
month ago i would have said the
ukrainian population had zero appetite
for a compromise especially if it came
to
uh putting aside its uh bid to become a
member of nato or the eu
uh now we're looking at a nation that in
many parts of ukraine as your
correspondent indicated has been bombed
into submission and the bombing
continues in places like kiev
but
it has to be said i cannot overestimate
this enough that uh there's a lot of
anger here on the streets in the view of
and elsewhere there's a lot of arms in
the hands of people
people are thinking back to the maidan
uh times of 24 2013 and 2014
and saying we did not spill our
children's blood for nothing we did not
show up there for nothing so
this could spiral out of control very
very quickly given the current
atmosphere uh so i think because a lot
excuse me zolensky is in a very very
tough spot
there just quickly there is of course an
appetite a very big appetite for the war
to stop but um
i actually predicted this some time ago
that zolensky may be pressured by
western allies to go for that kind of
compromise it's a very dangerous route
indeed let's go one step further if
there is any kind of compromise or
negotiated settlement uh peace deal even
who will be uh guaranteeing that
well that's a good question and you know
um
as much as the russians may be trying to
show their good side diplomatic side
whatever you want to call it are these
talks uh they're not to be trusted uh
they weren't uh they didn't they weren't
to be trusted in the you know the
guarantee of the safety of people
fleeing in those humanitarian uh
corridors uh there's now fears that
they're not uh doing well on the
battlefield so they may actually
escalate their use of shelling
escalate use of banned weapons and
possibly even turn to chemical weapons
so we're in very very dangerous
unchartered territory at the moment
ukraine and president zelinski in a
strong enough position domestically to
agree to any kind of negotiated
settlement you mentioned the anger in
the country before yeah
well his popularity ratings are an
all-time high he has surprised his most
fiercest critics in terms of stepping up
to the plate and becoming a war
president there's no training
you know to become a wartime president
like he has he's done extremely well
he's stood up to the russians second
biggest army in the world but again
because of the
various delicate conditions that we're
facing right now with this anger with
the high high death toll with a degree
of destruction um it's very very
difficult to predict whether he'd get
enough support from ukrainians to at
least temporarily shelve the nato bid i
think maybe that could be a kind of
compromise if uh zalansky told his
people that this is a temporary thing
just for us to regroup uh get the
russians out stop the bombing and
rebuild but it remains to be seen
michael barcequeue there from the
atlantic council think tank thank you
very much
pleasure thank you
top defense officials from nato
countries are discussing further help
for ukraine as the country fights back
against russia's invasion
ministers include u.s defense secretary
lloyd austin
are meeting in brussels austin repeated
that the alliance would abide by its
promise to protect the eastern european
member states
if russia launched an attack
but estonia a smaller nato member
bordering russia continued to call for
the alliance to set up a no-fly zone in
ukraine this is a step the alliance has
refused to take so far as ukraine is not
a member
but nato said it has to ensure the
conflict does not spill over into
ukraine's neighbors we are reinforcing
our collected events
hundreds of thousands of troops
on heightened alert
a hundred thousand troops u.s troops in
europe
and then
forty thousand
troops on the nato command directly to
command mostly in the eastern part of
the alliance
supported by naval and air forces nato
has a responsibility to ensure that this
crisis do not
escalate beyond ukraine and that's also
the reason why we have increased the
presence in eastern part alliance
let's bring in christine mundo in uh
brussels for more christine does
stoltenberg's statement effectively mean
that nato will not get involved in the
war in ukraine at all as long as a nato
member country is not attacked
that's right uh gerhard what we are
listening to is the secretary general
reiterating uh the nato alliance's
position that everything that nato is
doing the the long-term security
strategy that it's been discussing in
the meetings today uh all the defense
spending and all the uh the the
bolstering of units and all the
provisions and the measures that nato
was taking
are only
for the event that a nato member comes
under attack ukraine is not a nato
member
and will likely not be one we heard that
as well from the ukrainian president
vladimir zelinsky who on tuesday really
gave the most explicit acknowledgement
of the fact that ukraine's desire to
join nato uh would likely not be
realized um any time soon and it's
something that zielinski said
that he had accepted so nato has been
firm on its position that it does not
believe its direct involvement in this
conflict uh would bring an end to the
conflicts in fact the contrary nato's
position is that this would extend and
and expand this conflict
and take us to a place uh where world
war iii is is a closer reality than what
many people would like to think
so membership one thing weapons delivery
is another will nato continue to supply
weapons to ukraine
that's right i mean we heard that from
uh the u.s secretary of defense lloyd
austin who who came on record again
today to say that nato stands uh by
ukraine it supports ukraine's uh
right to be able to defend itself
against russia in the case of this
invasion reiterating again that nato
will continue to supply defensive
military uh equipment and weaponry to
the ukrainians we know for example the
dutch
defense minister also
reiterated uh the the netherlands
commitment and that they will continue
to send military aid to ukraine even as
these could be targeted these aid
convoys could be targeted
in russian attacks so nato's position is
that it does support ukraine financially
with military aid defensive military aid
to be able to defend itself because that
is a right
that it believes ukraine has and we will
support that to the full
so is nato membership for ukraine now
completely off the table forever
that is basically what it sounds like
and as i was pointing out those remarks
uh by vladimir zelinsky the president of
ukraine um really the most explicit
acknowledgement that he's at least come
out and said in public we know for
example the uk
prime minister boris johnson as well
completely took that off of the table to
say it's just not feasible it's not
likely it doesn't appear that there is
going to be a path for ukraine to be
joining nato or to be given nato
membership
at any time soon we are not going to see
nato engage on behalf of ukraine in
terms of confronting russia directly not
in the way of a no-fly zone on ukrainian
skies not in the way of sending troops
western troops
to ukraine so that is almost a
definitive yes at this stage
there are no indications no appetite
among nato's 30 allies
member states that there would be any
ukraine joining the alliance anytime
soon
dw correspondent christine mundo
reporting from brussels there thank you
christine
i'm not joined by ukrainian german
writer katya petrovskaya uh katja you
are currently in contact with people in
kiev you were born and raised there how
concerned are people there about
what nato is currently doing
people are concerned about what putin is
currently doing because uh you know just
to imagine that kia for which which is
supposed to be the first russian city
because christianity was adopted there
it's the most ancient russian city in
the in the perspective of history and
actually this city was
the the the knights of kiev founded
moscow
so it's really crazy situation um
people are
really asking for
maybe the the the most important plea in
kiev is to close the sky
and
the the answer of natto is no uh because
natto is uh concerned about escalation
point is that actually putin is um
is in war against nata already a long
time
and because he is like he even said that
even even sanctions again against russia
is a military measure so actually
we yeah can i can i just ask you you
have said that the west has a moral
obligation to intervene militarily in
the ukraine war including opposing a
no-fly zone but nato as we've heard uh
says there would be an escalation draw
nato member states into the war isn't
that a valid point you think
actually you know i'm not a military
expert but military experts are saying
that uh if not uh will insist uh sir it
will intervene in any
uh any kind of consul uh constellation
it would mean the the father's
escalation but uh but the point is that
uh putin is somebody who is escalating
without any kind of reason you know so
um uh the point with nato is not the
most important i think that uh there are
other possibilities like uh according to
uh to budapest memorandum uh uh like a
sort of constellation between us and
britain uh to to help ukraine maybe not
uh completely to close the sky but at
least to protect uh big cities uh um
um nuclear power plate stations uh and
uh and the
uh the way to lemberg to live
now ukrainian president rodriguez now
saying that ukraine could agree to a
central russian demand that ukraine will
not join nato in the future do you think
there will be support for a compromised
peace deal with russia if that helps to
end the war
i don't know but um i i really don't
know but um i think that zelensky are
looking for any possible
um
way to finish this war but at the same
time not to humiliate
his own country
just very briefly you also a german
citizen is germany doing enough to help
ukraine
i i still have only ukraine
understand thank you very much ukrainian
german writer katya petrovskaya
thank you